the thing is with me is I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] I don't give a
[__] what anybody says or what anybody
thinks I have this mindset I know
exactly who the [__] I am I have my
circle of people that I hang around with
who know me and know what I'm about and
whatever and uh anybody else who doesn't
like it or doesn't want to too [__]
bad I don't care you find out who's with
you and who's not when the [__] hits the
fan yeah you know what I mean I say this
all the time it happened with me and my
my employees during coid right during
coid they're laying people off and
whatever we didn't [__] lay anybody
off these didn't you negate some of your
salary or something what you guys do no
I said I would but okay I said we're
going to go through this we're not
laying anybody off we're going through
this yeah and
um you know every Christmas party I get
up on stage and tell my [__] team how
much I love them and how important they
are to me and then the scarest time in
our lifetime uh hits and I'm like hey
yeah I love you guys so much I'm going
to [__] lay you off some of you have
been with me 10 15 20 years I'm one of
these guys the whole [__] ship goes
down together or not at all we're all
[__] sinking me included or we don't
at all you know and and uh you know that
doesn't exist in in this world that we
live in today everybody's just so easy
to pull the trigger and let go of some
of their people and no it's something
good I need to hear that too you know
I'm just as my business grows I'm become
more of a boss I never wanted to be a
boss how how do you do this how do you
do this without these two I don't right
but I yeah and now that you said
Chistmas how do these two do this
appreciate that without you right you're
a [__] team I think we've realized
that more this year I think but it's
become a Learning lesson for me as a
boss you know it's like you think like I
need to just hold on but you really need
to let go and let others help you're a
you're a team you what you do is when
when you run a successful [__]
business you do it by building a really
good team around you you know and uh I I
have have you're you a lot of great
employees man I got the best team in the
world man I got 350 unfuckingbelievable
people when I said we're [__] storm
of the beach we're going definitely dude
nobody [__] said no there is no
experience man when I go to the UFC
fights it's like the whether it's the
assistants or your directors or um the
guys who were opening the cage door you
look over and there's like some hero ear
there's David Spade or there's M Gibson
or there's Joe burrow it's like you have
all of just like and it just feels like
you're in this fun [__] family that's
a little bit mentally unhanded right I'm
not gonna say that okay no you're not
wrong yeah this family not yeah this
family's had some [__] domestic
disputes all right but they uh but it
just dude it feels so much fun when I
leave the event I miss that I miss the
people that you work with just as much
as I miss the action that's awesome I I
I love hearing that and and thank thank
you and and you're not the first one to
tell me that everybody tells me that
anybody who interacts with anyone on my
team and and everybody here is is smart
hardworking the best at what they do and
there's no none of that [__] you
know at the office where there's all
this backstabbing and [__] all this
[__] those type of people we get rid
of immediately yeah you you you don't
last here being that kind of a person
this is a team this is a family and uh
we we throw parties here all the time
for all of our employees we we throw
different types of parties like parties
for the for the employees where they can
bring their their spouse or their wife
or whatever then we throw parties where
you can bring your kids because we want
their kids to come and see the place
where their parents work and they want
them to feel you know your parents are
gone at work all the time we want the
kids to look at where they go to work as
a fun place as as a place that's that
that's cool oh Mom and Dad are at work
we love going to their work yeah you
know what I mean oh [__] start a 37
PB weight class dude you know what I'm
saying yeah I mean awesome that's out of
line but because that's children
fighting but um was it hard for you to
learn to be a boss as your business grw
like what was some of the cuz man even
you just saying this in front of us man
it's important for us to hear because I
I I need to do a better job of it you
know and some of that is just stuff I'm
learning as my business has grown in my
responsibilities and not feeling like I
need to really try to do everything
myself you know I can be a better uh
boss and employ and and cooworker a lot
of times um so it's just powerful you're
saying that in front of us delegating
and respecting
people's ability to do stuff sometimes
I'm just I was always so used to doing
things myself growing up 100% no I get
listen I'm
still as successful as this thing has
been and all the stuff that we do I get
here every day at 9ine o' and and I'm
one of the last guys to leave this
building every night still um was it
hard to learn to be a boss like how did
you like have like a role model with
that or did you well I I I had my own
business before this but you know I
obviously wasn't the difference the only
difference in in coming to the UFC was
you
know the size you know and being a
global company and obviously the finance
side I mean you know I went from dealing
with hundreds of thousands of dollars to
dealing with hundreds of millions of
dollars so that that's the difference um
but you know Finance is not my [__]
thing we have a very strong Finance team
and you know one of the things I hated
the most in in being in this business
was [__] budget meetings man we used to
be in budget meetings you know when we
were getting murdered and we were losing
money we were in budget meetings for
[__] it felt like days and uh that
was the only not fun part of the
business for me and uh now where we are
now I only do the fun [__] I only do the
[__] that I really love to do and and
and I stay completely focused on which
is making sure the production the live
and in-house production is [__]
perfect um uh finding new
Talent uh putting on the best fights we
can possibly put on and start building
those are those are the things that I
really focus on um so more more
marketing I don't [__] with finances at
all yeah good yeah I mean just because
you like to gamble you know and because
[__] I I do too man so you know I
[__] I'm on some site now I can't
even get my money out of the [__]
thing like Jesus dude have you had
trouble do you ever have trouble like I
have trouble A lot of times feeling
proud of myself is something I've had
trouble with does has that ever been
something you've dealt with does that
make any sense when I ask you that I'm
never proud of myself I I I always look
at things like we're not even close
people ask me all the time do you ever
look around and say oh wow look at nuh
I'm always like what's next what's next
what's next yeah why do you think that
is do you think because I'm I'm that way
too it's hard for me to feel kind of
where I'm at sometimes because I always
have some Vision or something you know
that needs to be done yeah do do you
think that comes because I noticed it's
a commonality amongst some some folks do
you think there's any have you able to
get in touch with any of that and think
about that at all no I don't give a [__]
yeah I just keep [__] I just keep
plugging I just keep plugging man
there's just so much more work to be
done I just want to do as much as I can
do yeah until I can't do it anymore
yeah